[Music]
your family the first time Breanna is
not standing behind you in the opening
credits I know it broke my heart I just
got back from North Carolina last night
and she wanted to be done
she was really at a place in her life
with Ryan Ryan just retired disability
marine and they decided to move to North
Carolina where he's from and build a
life there and it broke my heart first
time in 13 years I haven't had my
daughter on the green screen and their
credits and it still makes me sad when I
just saw it the other day but I'm happy
for Breanna
her health is improving she works still
full time as a nurse and her husband
takes care of the boys and she's got a
four and six-year-old almost choice
almost six already we saw him being born
on camera and they're the love of my
life and so this is my new normal now
flying across country oh my gosh could
you move it any farther away this is not
like oh we can't wrap but so I'm doing
the red eyes out getting there in the
morning and just spending as much time
with them and then heading back home
it's my new normal so will we not see
her on the show at all this year Wow
first time first time she wanted to just
have a break and be kind of incognito
and you know keep the kids off camera
the unfortunate part about putting their
children on camera and yourself is the
trolls come out and the negative people
come out and the people that have their
opinion and she's like I don't want to
hear it anymore
I'm a good mother and a good wife and we
have a great family and I don't want to
hear any negativity and and that happens
you know people were trolling them bad
about Ryan or told him about her
it just gets exhausting
you
[Music]